ich habe heute nacht geträumt von dieser
tat die ich heute backen werde ich habe
mir gedacht ich mach eine tat mit einer
fruchtigen füllung einer käsekuchen
masse weil käsekuchen jeder lebt und ist
die perfekte silvesterpfad denn ich
werde aus marzipan so könnten formen und
dann die zahl 2022 jahreswechsel werde
ich auf die tat drauflegen dann kommt
also ein schoko deckel drauf dann sieht
man etwas drunter ist und dann um 0 uhr
um mitternacht wenn sie jahr 2021 vorbei
ist und deshalb 2022 kommt geht man da
mit dem heißluft und dann schmiss die
schokolade runter und 2022 erscheint
jetzt bin ich nur noch gespannt auf auch
so klappt wie ich mir das vorstelle
aber ich habe geträumt dass das wird das
wird
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine leckere tat zum
jahreswechsel und ich habe etwas richtig
cooles einfallen lassen ich hoffe es
gelingt auch ich habe nämlich davon
geträumt und ich glaube es ist die
perfekte tat zum silvester jahreswechsel
ich glaube es wird schön für die tat
werde ich jetzt erstmal einen möglich zu
bereiten das ist mein ganz normaler
standard 123 mio der besteht aus 100
gramm zucker 200 kalter butter 300 gramm
mehl 1 eigelb etwas vanille extrakt und
salz und wichtig ist bei mürbeteig das
einfach die zutaten kalt sind das heißt
butter und eigelb da könnt ihr die
butter in würfel schneiden und direkt
mit dem zucker verrühren ihr könnt auch
ein handrührgerät verwenden mit
knethaken oder wenn ihr habt könnt ihr
auch so einen teig zerdrücken nehmen
oder mit einem messer ihr könnt wirklich
auf jede art und weise herstellen
wichtig ist nur dass der teig nicht so
weich wird das heißt wirklich nur kurz
kneten ich führe jetzt kurz butter mit
zucker
wenn sich dann alles verrührt hat könnte
die übrigen zutaten dazugeben und den
teig kurz durchkneten und hier verwende
ich jetzt auch kein bug mail denn das
bak mail ist dafür wirklich zu fein und
da ist auch backpulver drittens möchte
ich nicht haben nehmen sie einfach ein
normales weizenmehl oder ihr verwendet
einen dinkelmehl 630 es geht auch gut
[Musik]
karben
jetzt ist der teig fertig der sieht noch
ein bisschen krümelig aus aber das passt
so auf jeden fall dann knetet ihr ihn
einfach ganz kurz mit den händen mal
zusammen
aber das ist wunderbar aus und da muss
jetzt einmal in den kühlschrank für eine
stunde etwa dass sich schön durch kühlt
der zucker sich auch gut lösen kann und
damit das ganze nicht so lange dauert
und drücke ich den immer gerne flach auf
einen teller dann schön abdecken und
eine stunde kalt stellen und ich kann
ihnen der zwischenzeit schon mal die
frucht füllung machen da ich mir nämlich
gedacht mach' ich eine kirche
überfüllung dann wird es noch richtig
leckere tat dafür nehme ich 300 gramm
himbeeren dass ihr jetzt gefrorene ein
glas sauerkirschen samt fruchtsaft etwas
tonka banker oder zuckerpaste 25 gramm
stärke und 40 gramm zucker die himmel
gebe ich jetzt hier in den topf und dann
nehme ich mir ein bisschen war es vom
fruchtsaft
einfach nur zum anrühren der stärke
damit jetzt nicht klumpt dann kurz
berühren
und das wird jetzt einfach eingetaucht
wie so eine art pudding
dann gibt jetzt einfach alles in den
topf samt tonka passte ihr könnt auch
ihr tonkabohne verwenden und ein
bisschen was dazu reiben aber beim
schreiben der tonkabohne einfach darauf
achten dass sie nicht zu viel nehmt
wirklich nur eine kleine prise oder ihr
könnt die tonkabohne im ganzen auch kurz
mitkochen dann wieder rausnehmen wo beim
nächsten mal weiter verwenden da ein
bisschen zucker
und wirklich alles zugießen und
aufkochen
[Musik]
jetzt ist es soweit und durfte einmal
aufkochen die sitzt auch schön
dickflüssig ihr könnt jetzt gerne stück
ich lassen oder pürieren ich muss sagen
bei uns sind nicht alle fans von
stückchen deswegen werde ich es jetzt
auch pürieren dann liegt sie auch
flacher in der form drin gleich
als einmal mit früher starb
[Musik]
jetzt lass ich es aber noch mal ein
bisschen einkochen denn die kirchen
verlieren jetzt auch noch mal ihr wasser
und das ist es noch mal ein bisschen
flüssiger geworden als gerade eben das
sieht man jetzt ganz gut jetzt einfach
nur mal zwei drei minuten einkochen
damit die flüssigkeit verdunsten kann
seit dem masters fertig wundert euch
jetzt nicht ich habe die doppelte daher
gemacht weil wir heute zweiter arzt zu
bereiten also bei euch ist es dann die
halbe menge aber ich habe die richtige
mengenangabe für euch angegeben also mit
einem halben glas sauerkirschen falls
ihr übrigens keine himbeeren oder
sauerkirschen mögt dann könnt ihr das
natürlich auch austauschen ihr könnt
auch andere früchte verwenden und wenn
ihr sagt ihr mögt auch keine himberg
herrmann
ich bin ja sagt er wird keinen ihm bei
kerner dann könnt ihr die auch jetzt
kurz raus 7 also mit einem feinen heber
dann habt ihr die auch weg und habt
wirklich nur noch dieses fruchtpüree und
dann ist da auch nichts mehr drin was
stört aber ich muss sagen ich mag es
ganz ehrlich stürzt hier zumindest
deswegen lasse ich das jetzt hier drin
so kurz umfüllen dass es schön abkühlen
kann und dann kann ich mich eigentlich
auch schon gleich um den mürbeteig
kümmern denn da ist jetzt auch gleich so
weit
dann habe ich jetzt hier den kalten und
den rolle ich jetzt auf eine leicht beim
bak matte auf der silicon matte schön
groß aus und zwar nehme jetzt gleich
hier diese tat form mit hebe boden der
hebel boden ist dafür da dass man später
die gebackene und fertig dekoriert tat
einfach auslösen kann er kennt
wahrscheinlich alle diese backformen die
den festen boden haben und dann kriegt
man die tat hat ohne daraus war im
prinzip müsste man sie raus stürzen da
geht sie aber kaputt und deswegen habe
ich hier einfach diesem tag boden den
hebel boten die backform kann ich dann
auch kurz vettel mit back trance break
wobei ich muss sagen oftmals reicht
sogar das fett im web aber
sicher ist sicher
und die backform hat jetzt ein
durchmesser von 30 zentimetern und ich
wollte den teig ist einfach größer aus
auf etwa 36 damit ich den rand hier auch
noch schön hoch bekommen und ihr könnt
jetzt entweder einen aus holz stark mit
diesen abstand bringen nehmen die ich
hier außen gerne drauf haben und könnte
das ganze dann auf 3 oder 5 mm dicke
ausrollen oder er versucht einfach so
recht gleichmäßig hinzubekommen das
könnt ihr dann selbst entscheiden
ich drehe den einfach immer wieder
auch das immer so eine kleine schicht
und eine dünne schicht mail darunter ist
auch
beim plätzchenteig ist es wichtig aber
nicht so viel damit der mütter eben
nicht trocken wird
dann löst sich wieder gut
und ich kann die größe hier jetzt
einfach auf der matte ablesen
[Musik]
dann könnt ihr das ganze hier auf ein
aus rolf starb aufrollen
und dann vorsichtig reinlegen
[Musik]
und direkt diesen rand reindrücken damit
er gar nicht erst abbricht dann kann man
das schön in die backform reindrücken
falls er doch mal reist ist es auch
nicht schlimm so wie jetzt hier drückte
das einfach hier schon fest und dafür
muss der teig hat echt gut durch gekühlt
sein will wenn er das nicht ist ich habe
auch schon oft den teig einfach benutzt
vor der kühl zeit und dann und dann
reist der halt so da braucht wirklich so
diese zeit im kühlschrank und dann
klappt es auch wirklich perfekt
und den rest nimmt jetzt einfach mit
einer palette ab oder mit einem stumpfen
messer und drückt den praktisch von
innen nach außen so drückt ihr den teig
am rand noch mal schön fest und die ab
dem schönen sauberen abschluss
perfekt so sieht super aus die wird
jetzt noch eingefroren so bleibt sie
nämlich beim backen schönebeck stabil
und sorgt auch dafür dass der teig an
der form nicht runter rutscht das ist
nämlich auch oft so ein fehler den man
macht dass man die tat jahren fertig
dekoriert ist oder fertig ausgekleidet
ist einfach zu kurz kühlt und dann
rutscht der teig weil die mutter dann zu
weich ist am rand wieder runter und
deswegen wird es jetzt sie eingefroren
den restlichen teig hier könnt ihr
nehmen und keine kekse backen zum
beispiel das ist praktischen
plätzchenteig oder ihr könnt auch weil
ich später ja noch ne marzipan schicht
dazu verwenden werde um diese zahl 2022
zu formen könnt ihr auch aus dem aus dem
teig auch die 2022 vor wenn ihr sagt ihr
mit später kein marzipan und dafür nimmt
er den teig einfach rollt ihnen ebenso
eine rolle könnte an euch die zahl legen
so wie ihr sie möchte und die daneben im
ofen mit backen und dann habt ihr später
auch diese zahl die wir brauchen aber
ich werde später aus marzipan machen
deswegen kann ich daraus kekse backen
und den teig kurz einfrieren und in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die käsekuchen
masse machen
für die käsekuchen masse nämlich 60 g
weiche butter 100 g zucker 1 ein eiweiß
etwas vanille extrakt 250 gramm
magerquark 25 gramm stärke 200 gramm
sahne und etwas abtrieb und saft einer
zitrone
das könnte jetzt auch endlich mit dem
handrührgerät mit der küchenmaschine
oder aber mit einem schneebesen machen
mit dem schneebesen einfach die weiche
butter mit dem zucker verrühren
ich glaube das habe ich es jetzt auch
noch nie schaumig gerührt
gewesen
wo sie doch gar nicht so wahnsinnig
schaumig gerührt werden und dann gebt
ihr das ei dazu
und das eiweiß das eigelb hatte ich ja
im teig mit verwendet und ich finde es
immer ganz gut 80 auch den rezepten echt
oft drauf dass praktisch schon immer das
komplette verwertet wird und dann hat
man auch nichts 70
[Musik]
dann vanille extract dazu geben
ich finde das ist jetzt auch so ein
bisschen so back to the roots einfach so
komplett ohne küchenmaschine ohne alles
ich finde es wäre sogar ein format was
wir machen könnten und er macht dann
diese challenge schreibt hin backe diese
oder diese torte ohne und dann könnte er
so das werkzeug schreiben was ich nicht
benutzen darf und dann muss ich das halt
irgendwie alternativ machen
wow das könnte aber eskalieren glaube
ich auch genau machen schreibt gern mal
in die kommentare dann können wir gucken
ob es geht
wie sehr es mich an die grenze bringt
sagt dazu
dann auch die stärke einrühren
aber erst jetzt hat die mama früher das
gemacht auch ein rührkuchen und dann
wird er die butter mit den eiern
wirklich richtig lange geschlagen und
dann hat man eben so die luft unter
gehoben
wenn dann alles glatt berührt ist
die sahne langsamer zu gießen
also ich finde das ist die schönste
käsekuchen maße die ich je gemacht habe
gebe ich eine prise zitronen abrieb dazu
und da achtet er darauf dass die schale
zum verzehr geeignet ist
und dann ein spritzer zitronensaft
ihr könnt auch alternativ zitronen
passte verwenden diese passte
hat praktisch von zitronensaft und
zitronenschale mit drin
die masse ist fertig jetzt kein staat
will dann kommt ihr hier die abgekühlte
frucht füllung 1
ihr könnt ihr auch einfach einen
käsekuchen mit mandarinen machen wenn
jedes lieber mögt aber ich finde frucht
und tonga das ist echt so eine mischung
es gibt mittlerweile einfach zu meinen
lieblingen dann schön verteilen
ich glaub noch ein bisschen damit die
luft entweichen kann und
befreit sie die käsekuchen masse drauf
kommt werde ich die tat inklusive frucht
füllung jetzt erst mal für etwa 15
minuten vor backen den ofen heizt sich
gerade noch vor solange stelle ich das
kurz ins gefrierfach das wirkt dann
nämlich dann so dass praktisch diese
frucht bildung sondern art haut bekommt
und dann die käsemasse drauf kommt und
sich das ganze eben nicht verbindet und
jetzt am besten noch mal kurz einfrieren
oder in den kühlschrank stellen falls
ihr kein großes gehabt und dann im
vorgeheizten ofen 15 minuten backen
[Musik]
die backzeit überbrücke ich jetzt und
werde diese schokoladen decke herstellen
und dafür habe ich mir jetzt gedacht
nämlich satt bitterschokolade ihr könnt
aber auch jede andere sorte verwenden
wichtig ist einfach nur dass die zart
bitterschokolade temperiert wird also
vor kristallisiert wird damit die samen
als man denkt und sagt ich damit dieser
schokoladen deckel einfach schön fest
ist und schön glänzt obendrauf ich nehme
jetzt ungefähr so 220 230 gramm und zum
perfekten temperieren nehmt jetzt am
besten die zwei drittel also so ungefähr
160 gramm und gibt es jetzt hier über
ein warmes wasserbad
und da achte ich einfach immer drauf ich
lasse das wasser aufkochen stellt den
herd aus stellt dann das schmelz
schälchen drüber und kann die kuvertüre
schmelzen bis sie wirklich perfekt
geschmolzen ist ihr könnt auch ganz
gerne die mikrowelle verwenden dafür
einfach in der mikrowelle etwa 6 800
watt ungefähr eine minute erst mal
schmelzen dann rühren und dann immer
wieder 10 20 sekunden lang schmelzen bis
die kuvertüre ebenso weit ist
und jetzt habe ich hier die flüssige
kuvertüre die hat jetzt ungefähr 50 grad
und damit die jetzt praktisch in dieser
schöne kristallstruktur kommt die wir
bei der schokolade brauchen gebe ich das
restliche drittel dazu zum
herunterkühlen wieder
jetzt einfach immer schön rühren bis
alles geschmolzen ist und was ich dann
nur noch machen muss ist folgendes ich
werde dann nur noch ganz kurz für ein
zwei sekunden aufs wasser darstellen
oder mit dem heißluft 5-mal so bekommt
ihr einfach die perfekte temperatur
kurve hin erst die schokolade erwärmen
dann runterkühlen und dann nur noch ganz
minimal erwärmung und dann wird sie
wirklich wunderbar
wenn am ende gerade so zwei drei kleine
kügelchen an schokolade noch habt geht
es echt immer ganz gut mit dem heißluft
füllen wurde ihr drückt wirklich hier an
den rand und setzt das ganze noch mal
ganz kurz aufs wasser bat
wenn ihr denkt dass sie gut ist eine
tankkarte sowie hier einfach so eine
kunststoff teig karte taucht die ecke
hinein und legt dann detail karte
einfach auf der arbeitsplatte ab so
könnt ihr sehen dass die schokolade wenn
sie wirklich perfekt ist einfach
innerhalb von einer minute ungefähr
schon schön anzieht und festwirt mit
schönen glanz hat wenn sie innerhalb von
ein bis zwei minuten nicht anzieht heißt
sie es einfach noch zu warm und dann
gebt ihr noch ein bisschen kuvertüre
dazu wenn sie zu schnell fest wird seht
ihr sie es zu kalt dann muss man noch
mal erwärmt werden jetzt die kuvertüre
soweit und man sieht es hier auch ganz
schön die hat einen richtig schönen
glanz und ich nehme jetzt hier meinen
drehteller
packte den untersetzer drauf und eine
tortenplatte und tabak folie ihr könnt
aber auch backpapier verwenden jetzt ist
einfach nur wichtig ihr braucht was wo
ihr jetzt praktisch diese schoko platte
darauf diesen könnt also hier schön
drauf geben
und ich nehme einfach die dreh platte
weil es gleich einfacher ist zum
verteilen
mit der palette schön verstreichen
[Musik]
und die schallplatte sollte jetzt etwa
so groß sein wie die tat formen ihr
könnt euch das woche ausmessen meine ist
30 cm groß ich habe hier nämlich noch
den karton davon den ich immer so
zwischen rhein legt damit nichts
verkratzt und das ist jetzt ungefähr so
groß ihr könnt aber auch einen teller
verwenden oder eine schablone vorher
machen
oder wenn die tat später gebacken ist
und wir den boden schon gelöst habt
könnt ihr auf den boden dafür verwenden
also ein bisschen zum
abgleichen und am besten nicht so dick
das heißt falls doch ein bisschen zu
viel schokolade isst gerne abstreifen
aber ich hab ein bisschen mehr
geschlossen als ich gesagt habe deswegen
passt scho also so ungefähr 210 bis 240
gramm sind okay
und wenn es dann gleichmäßig verteilt
ist dann einfach in den kühlschrank
stellen oder hier bei raumtemperatur
wenn euer raum nicht so warm ist kann
das aber raumtemperatur fest werden
lassen und es muss jetzt auch gar nicht
so perfekt sein also ihr könnt auch hier
gerne so ein bisschen muster reinziehen
aber das wird später sowieso noch ein
bisschen hübsch gemacht
so
das heißt ich bin jetzt eigentlich fast
schon fertig mit der tat die tat macht
dann dass ich sie später komplett
abkühlen die waren dann in den
kühlschrank die schokoladen platte kommt
auch in den kühlschrank und das einzige
was ich damit machen muss das ist die
marzipan dekoration die mache ich jetzt
gleich noch ein stellt die auch in den
kühlschrank oder kann ich später alles
schön zusammensetzen
wenn die tagesmutter backen ist könnt
ihr hier jetzt die masse drauf geben
ganz vorsichtig
doch wirklich vorsichtig sein dass unten
diese frucht schlicht nicht zerstört
wird und dann im ofen fertig backen
ich nehme es immer ganz gerne mit einem
torten retter
und handschuhe
und dann kann nämlich die tat fertig
backen und ich kann mich um die
dekoration noch kümmern
[Musik]
also für die marzipan zahl nehme ich
jetzt hier mein marzipan in very caritas
hat gleicht diesen kirsch gesorgt
und dafür formt jetzt einfach diese zahl
ihr könnt jetzt hier mit
2022 formen oder ihr könnt auch eine
figur formen so ein herzchen zum
beispiel oder was anderes weil man kann
ja daraus das ganze nicht nur als
sylvester torte sondern eben auch als
überraschungs tor zu machen wichtig ist
dass die zahl nicht zu dick und zu hoch
werden sondern dann relativ flach
gedrückt werden ich mache das jetzt mal
so und dann werde ich mir das so hin wie
mir das gefällt
[Musik]
falls das ganze ein bisschen klebt könnt
ihr ein bisschen becker stärke
drüberstreuen dann klebt nicht so sehr
an den händen und dann weg so ein
bisschen flach drücken so dass die
zahlen einfach so etwa fünf millimeter
hoch sind weil sie so große buchstaben
ausstecher oder zahlen aus studie habt
könnt ihr die natürlich auch nehmen und
es vorher einfach nur ausrollen und
ausstechen aber ich finde so dass jetzt
hier zu formen das geht auch ganz
einfach und dann stelle ich es kurz ins
gefrierfach also heute aber wirklich so
ein gefrierfach thema mit der tat aber
das macht jetzt einfach nur dann einfach
addiert die zahlen drauf zu legen ihr
könnt sie aber auch direkt auf den
kuchen legen den kuchen habe ich jetzt
im kühlschrank so wieder schön kalt und
dann sind wir echt gleich fertig ich bin
schon gespannt
richtig aufgeregt ob es klappt
jetzt kann ich hier meine tat
herauslösen schön vorsichtig die weit im
kühlschrank
dann den hebel boten ablösen das geht am
besten mit einem messer oder mit einer
palette da müssen wir vorsichtig sein
und einmal zwischen kuchen boden und tat
boden am besten nehmt ihr sogar die
palette so rum an der tischkante und
dann könnte die nämlich hier so einmal
durchziehen und dann ist der boden
abgelöst habe ich die tat auf eine
platte gesetzt dann kommen da die zahlen
drauf
so wie es ruhig dann gefällt
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr hier diese schoko platte
gerne noch mit glitzer puder bemalen
dann nehme ich es einfach diese
lebensmittelfarben den gold und
dann noch ein bisschen
in diesem dunkelrot
[Musik]
und da einfach mit dem pinsel so ein
bisschen verteilen mit einem trockenen
[Musik]
noch 1700 besonders aus arbeits kommt
die schoko platte da drauf so und jetzt
wenn ihr habt die hinterachse
luftweg heißluft boehner dann stellt ihr
das ganze einfach in den ofen oben rein
ich weiß doch sonst sind auch probiert
halt einfach mein gott ich wollte halt
die technik so wahr machen und wenn er
kann also schön habt und das im ofen
nicht ausprobieren wollt dann legt
einfach die schoko platte drauf und ich
mache die bahn teile oben drüber dann
könnte er den effekt halt vielleicht
nicht machen aber ich hab mir gedacht
ich probiere zeit aus so ganz einfach ok
also ein frohes neues jahr
jetzt lasst uns mal
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
weiter
[Musik]
auch jetzt noch mal bissel silvester in
der house
jesus okay kommt einer kommt schnell
kommt
so wie machen wir das jetzt
als sowie
kommt zusammen zusammen zu sein ich gehe
runter wir wünschen euch ein frohes
neues jahr
das wäre das letzte video im jahr
eigentlich nett weil die tat muss man
anpacken kann auch jedes wird nicht das
letzte lied in mir aber trotzdem wünsche
ok dann wünschen wir euch noch vor
weihnachten weil es kommt jetzt auch
noch und ein schönes neues jahr und es
[Musik]
steht doch gibt es dabei gibt es noch
keinen sommer
[Gelächter]
kevin legt das fahrzeug bitte
ihr seid ja besser als hier ist ein
besseres publikum als 2 wie ist denn das
topfgeldjäger da war immer einer dabei
oder davon wahrscheinlich nicht verraten
aber kommen die sendung gibt es schon
lange nicht mehr da sitzt immer einer im
publikum bei so essens sendungen und er
macht immer den anstecker für
und a
über
also ich war jetzt ein bier für dich so
kommt hier mache schnelle produktion
der als ich muss echt sagen dass ich
besser aus als gedacht
kann jemand der bewertung abgeben
käsekuchen
sieht sehr gut aus doch so wirklich sehr
sehr gut gemacht und der effekt ist auch
sehr gut von mir
und im hauptsaal kuchen
also probiert das konzept gerne mal auf
ich hoffe dass wieder so ein schock
[Gelächter]
ich hatte einen schock diese lücke er
probiert das rezept gerne mal auf
wie gesagt wir den heißen habt dann
klappt das mit dem effekt doch ganz cool
wäre dann stellst hat wirklich den
backofen ansonsten mein gott bestreicht
den google hat mit flüssiger schokolade
geht auch gut
also viel spaß beim warmmachen bis zum
nächsten mal frohes neues jahr schöne
weihnachten bis nächste woche
[Musik]